some very disturbing video of Donald
Trump associate Roger stone who has
since been indicted and sentenced has
been released stone appears absolutely
out of control in this video I'm going
to play it for you this was recorded
February 12th and 13th the video is of
Roger stone giving testimony in a South
Florida Court Reporters office check out
the video you can hear some of the
craziness including stones swearing and
saying all sorts of incredible things
but if you're watching you will notice
the teeth clenching you'll notice the
grimacing you'll notice while calling
people [ __ ] you'll be able to both
hear and see truly and out of control
man take a look at this I'm not going to
discuss the criminal case if you want to
keep insulting me this will be over a
little [ __ ]
if you want to keep insulting me I will
just end this you go running back to the
judge did you tell me a bit you're
acting like one
this proves not that's what you told
molar right you got nothing I'm not
gonna be badgered by the same standard
yes I am yes I am you could fool me as
you can see his hands shaking his lips
quivering it's just a completely
different image to the one where Eustace
yes please do I like to judge myself
about this let her do it quick before
you're just hard stop stop mr. clean no
further divergences and is concluded for
now subject to my going back and moving
the court to produce all the documents
that we requested subject used to be
admitted this is very disturbing video
and it was filmed before Roger stone
sentencing which came last week stone
ultimately sentenced to three years in
prison in part because of his
threatening language which as you can
see from the video he does seem to have
a penchant for issuing threats and
attacking people directly in some sense
if indeed a pardon is incoming from
Donald Trump this is all for nothing
right like if if stone really suspects
he's going to ultimately be pardoned by
Donald Trump why even bother losing your
mind on people and the answer is he
can't control it and as I've told before
I've told the story before I interviewed
Roger stone a couple years ago on the
show and he had a book at the time and
you know he was doing some publicity
around it and when we connected with him
for the interview as we often do a few
minutes before the start time one of his
a staffers or somebody picked up the the
Skype call and then we saw Roger stone
come around the corner and we overheard
Roger stone basically saying very angry
with his staffer that somehow somebody
at some point agreed to do an interview
with me do we really have to do this at
this point in time and then they had a
conversation and sort of agreed I guess
at this point we don't have a choice
were connected and we're ready to go and
he was angry then with his staffer and
he seems like an angry guy unable to
control himself and that is what we see
in this video as well but my question to
you is is this guy getting pardoned
ultimately by Donald Trump let me know
what you think I think there is a very
very good chance if you ever feel like
you just don't have enough time to read
all the books you want to read you have
to check out one of my favorite apps
called blinka splink a' stakes thousands
of popular non-fiction books and
distills each one down into an e-book or
audio book that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 20
five percent off a subscription when you
go to blink is comm slash Pakman I've
put the link right underneath this video